don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed
hey babe hey baby what's up we're in
sugarland texas that's what's up sugar
sugarland as the spanish called asukar
texas
oh wow you do know some spanish
texas
um so sugarland texas if i lived here i
think subconsciously
and i don't know if this is possible i
would eat even more sugar and sweets
than i currently do because it feels
like it's always on the mind it's always
on the mind it's like almost like a
commercial for sugar yeah why did they
name this place sugar land it has to be
a fact
it's a good question now we were told by
the the the guy who's opening all the
shows who's fantastic chris johnston
that houston is the fattest city
simultaneously and also the most in
shape city yeah in the country it makes
no sense it makes no sense so if you're
from houston and we know that you are
are you are you fat or skinny yeah are
you skinny fat are you fat are you
skinny skinny fat fat skinny what would
you rather be right okay ready for this
we should put some air on in here
go ahead if you had if you had a choice
yeah okay
now here's the thing listen listen to
the whole thing through okay
if you
if you have if you could be you have to
either be morbidly obese sure but you
can't lose the weight you're staying
like that or
be
a little bit overweight but have no leg
you're no a little bit overweight but
you're just a torso no arms or legs so
you're either a torso
you're either an in-shaped torso or
you're an obese person that cannot lose
a pound but you have full function of
your arms and legs
yeah are you like is it like 600 pound
life whether they need a crane
no you can get around but barely you're
this close to needing a motorized
scooter like go to the deli okay but uh
when i'm in shape torso do i have my
you're fully jacked yeah but how do i
get around that way
you're you're just in such good shape
that you find a way
take me through finding a way without
limbs
you're just your role you've used a way
to use your body you don't have any
assistance he's not a caretaker you have
no caretaker and you can't have
prosthetics
well i gotta imagine i was gonna say
i'll be whatever one's more mobile
and practical but i have to imagine i
want i'd want limbs i mean you'd want
limp yeah i have to imagine right right
you can't lose the weight i know both
are really tough if you're that immobile
that you can't then you can't lose it
yeah but you can't i mean no no limbs
all right
i think i shout out people with no limbs
shout out god bless you okay the buy
pimp has pulled up the bayou city which
i i assume is houston right the bayous
oh sugarland the bayou city uh half an
hour southwest of houston got its name
from the product it produced for nearly
two centuries sugar sugar land served as
the site of major u.s sugar should have
been our first guess yes
sugar main sugar refinery distribution
center from 1843 until the refinery
shuttered its doors in 2003. well if
it's been shut since 2003 that's almost
20 years what let's rename sugarland
let's rename it what should we rename it
let's rename it aspartame land because
it's better than sucralose sucralose
ville
sucraloseville all right you ready you
ready please you can play this at home
here's the game and we're going to play
it intermittently throughout the podcast
you have to say five things in a row
whatever topic and if you take a breath
and even think about it for a second
you're out you're ready you're playing
it on the bus all day you ready yes okay
give me it babe i'm ready three i'm in a
full zone you have it already yep ready
yeah five cereals go okay tricks lucky
charms reese's puffs cheerios honey nut
cheerios i messed up no but
what do you guys think at home should we
should sal be assassinated for that you
you haven't i was almost doing your
technique the clap for the clap now
listen throughout the pond just just hit
me with it and we'll do it we'll keep
going back all right um
so i mean you guys have to talk about
sal's hotel experience uh
oh yeah okay sal
let me set it up sal we checked into a
hotel uh in san antonio
i won't say the name saying anthony
room867
um we checked it to hotel
now we were a little bit late they
didn't have the rooms ready things
happened but when sal checked into well
we were we was five o'clock they should
have the rooms ready we should have the
rooms ready yeah sorry if you guys are
hearing the the music upstairs we're in
the basement of the uh of the what is
this called the smart financial center
yeah in sugarland texas right this is
massive it's massive it's massive it's
built four years ago everything's state
of the art they have moving walls in the
theater yes they have moving walls in
the theater it's fantastic and you're
hearing them test the music system uh
upstairs and the reason why you're
hearing the reverberations down here is
because there's no people up there
[Laughter]
and it's just about show time
they were like uh they were showing us
like look the walls can move in they are
actual
like uh motored walls that move in or
whatever you see that one over there and
then we looked at the left and the other
one wasn't moved in what about this one
he goes i broke last night
literally last night who the hell was in
here last night that was breaking the
motorized walls yeah well i don't know
who it was it must have been uh maybe it
was g-eazy yeah g-e who could who sells
more tickets
hey bay podcast or g-eazy pimp who do
you think
maybe easy
that's not the realm of possibility yeah
but what what what would you want to ask
i'll tell you about ballsy i think his
name is jerry his real name is jerry tt
jerry interviews g-eazy jerry because
he's because i watched his architectural
digest open door and i took a tour of
his home interesting
he calls it jerryville or something like
that yeah and i got austin texas okay
cool all right
all right
columbus ohio at the palace theater
tonight
cincinnati ohio at the taft theater
tomorrow
sal volcano and i co-headlining doing 30
40 minutes to stand up each then coming
out and doing a mini habit at the end
come be part of the show it's been
amazing babe it's been amazing and then
january 14th and 15th i'll be at the
vulcan gas company in austin texas go to
christiecomedy.com for those ticky wikis
january 14th i am in des moines january
15th i am in indianapolis and january
16th i am at the agora in cleveland ohio
get those tickets to savolcanocomedy.com
what yeah yeah
wow nice place if you're watching and we
know that you are way nothing more i
can't believe you clicked on that video
oh i watch every architectural digest
i've seen everyone like 20 times what's
your favorite architecture
i swear to god
[Music]
uh i don't know um
uh oh now i'm on the spot well well you
said jeezy wasn't bad 50 episodes um no
it's not it's great it's like cribs but
like they really do well on the
architecture and design
speaking of architectural digest uh jake
paul and logan paul uh just announced
today that they're both individually
buying 22 million dollar penthouses in
the same miami condo in the same miami
building that's being built 22 million
uh uh penthouses each one of them have
three bedrooms you know three floors
bottle stickers and their own pools in
the condo both of them and they're
living next door to each other
in miami they have a pool in their
apartment in west philadelphia born and
raised
there's pools in the apartment buildings
yes in their in their apartment in their
apartment so and there was also a pool
for the for the residents but they have
their own pool wow so it's called a
plunge pool which i don't know what that
means oh okay what's up that's just like
a a smaller pool like a soap it's a
bathtub
it's yeah
it's not that impressive oh so so the
plunge pool is like not that big no it's
like it's like basically like a couple
people go in it they have peasants huh
yeah i mean plunge pool i mean why
couldn't you get what are we doing i've
seen people with an olympic
insider
indoors does it smell
what does it
yeah well i'm just joking
yeah but didn't you see didn't you i
don't know if we talked about hey babe
when you went to like somebody really
walty's house in england and their pool
like their floor retracted did we talk
about that
because that's sometimes like that keeps
me up at night yeah thinking about that
but you never finished like five in the
world hotel oh sals hotel san antonio
story um um when you checked into your
so what happened was is i get into my
room i get up to my floor my not my key
card wasn't working the actual battery
on the door was dead it didn't work so
i'm going down on the elevator and then
i had to replace the door they had to
replace the act well no they just put me
in another room just a full other room
then
i'm coming in the elevator to go down to
the lobby to be like hey my you know and
sal's girl is getting in the elevator
and she says
we
need to change rooms so what happened
and she says what did she what what did
you say
on the comforter and a baby crib there
was a crib in the room
and i think probably the people behind
right before us had a baby and i think
they just left because the reason the
rooms were already at five is they said
they had titanium members right
now there was blood on the sheets
because they had the baby in the room
what are you saying well i don't know
the blood on the blood on the comforter
i don't know if it came from the baby
but there was a crib in the room and
they didn't remove the crib and it
smelled like diapers and that and that
crib looked like it looked like an old
school crib the picture showed me where
it's a little it was a little haunting
yeah it was like a little bit like i
don't know maybe there was a moyle in
there what's a moyle you don't know what
a moyle is
a rabbi yeah oh so you think they had a
full brisk and they were sucking the
blood out of circumcised people no you
don't know
is it very hot in here
it's a little hot okay i don't know the
difference between br bris and brosh i
always get that
what's a brooch
a brooch a brooch what's a bris and a
brooch and what's uh what's a um which
is the one for the jewish boys and which
is the one for the jewish girls what's
the difference you just i'm mitzvah and
bar mitzvah never bot is female bar is
male 1 well how do you remember that but
uh because bar mitzvah's
i don't know how you remember anything i
used to bartend a lot of bar mitzvahs
okay so you can think about it here's
here's a quick way to remember it for
for any of our jewish people at home or
people who want to who are studying
judaism bar mitzvah is for boys and when
you think about that is bar
is it's very um phallic a bar it looks
field of penis
bat
b-a-t is also very foul it's that's even
more phallic than bar directly no bat
bat makes me think of china and china
are [ __ ] no i'm kidding
i'm kidding this is the wrong podcast
no i didn't want you almost got chaotic
i didn't want to bring up the
conversation you guys had about the
hotel sheets okay so let me tell you
something about this hotel sheets and we
were talking about this two days ago we
were talking about this we were in
dallas then we went to san antonio now
in sugar land but in dallas i made a
statement to you guys in the room and i
said while i was eating uh shrimp
fettuccine alfredo at 11 30 at night
with a baked apple pie and a skillet i
said to you which i only had 800
calories left so i went over um what i
said to you was i'm confident that most
hotel services maids and all that don't
fully change the sheets they spray
the sheets to like disinfect stuff and
you are almost always sleeping on sheets
that weren't really changed they were
just sprayed i i can't believe that to
be true i had to believe there's a law
okay but then the very next day you
check it to a hotel that has blood on
the sheets yeah so that was excellent
timing on your part so i mean you know
the spray didn't get all of it out now
sheets are usually changed it says
pimpled up sheets are usually changed
between guests and sometimes state law
requires it but there's no guarantee
which is all we've gotten tonight we're
not in the bonus that they will be
as for bed spreads forget it they said
for bedspreads forget it countless
hidden camera investigative tv programs
have confirmed they aren't washed
regularly okay so forget it on the
bedside i i took for granted already i i
mean not for granted i took as i assumed
always stay away from the bread spread
don't lay on the bed
because they can't they can't launder
bed spreads every time the sheets i got
to be honest if if the case is that the
sheets are not really being washed and
they're being febreze and we're not
being told i want to do a class action
lawsuit
with every listener we have i will i
will be the
there has to be someone on the podcast
that either you work in the in the hotel
industry and know inside or your mom or
dad or family member has please email
the podcast heybaypodcast gmail.com or
just dm us and let us know because i
really want to know like if you ever you
know like you've told us behind the
scenes secrets of what a deli looks like
we've had people tell us what happens in
you know food chain restaurants what
happens in the what are we sleeping on
are we sleeping in fecal matter and nail
clippings and bed like what are we
actually sleeping in i will tell you i
saw an investigative report uh
in on on on the television and uh i saw
uh they had a hidden cameras in there
and uh i guess what do you call them the
room cleaners
i say made is that is that is that like
no no what about you because a male's
not a maid cleaning person
okay so i thought maters like from from
maiden i don't know i don't even know
could be right but anyway
don't ever ever ever ever never never
ever ever ever ever
use the glassware
really yes i mean wish i knew about that
about an hour i know i mean maybe at
nicer establishments they're a little
bit more buttoned up but they had them
in like um and they would they would
just rinse them out only or
they would clean them with the rag that
they're dusting everything else with so
like they'll go in the room and they'll
spray windex and they'll clean like the
tops or something and then they just
picked up the glass redness just went
like that with the actual dirty dusty
windexed rag yeah in the in the glass i
mean you know what honestly never since
that day years ago i've never ever ever
used a glass the thing is though when
you're drunk enough like you know what i
mean it doesn't matter i don't really i
can't i can't recall a time that when
i've really used the glassware i've
definitely done it but i can't recall a
time when
you know cause they're always turned
over i don't think i barely use it glass
of water by the bed alka seltzer
babes i bottled water bottled water by
the bed and i i have many many many many
many times put my face like run the
water in the bathroom sink and drank
directly from the faucet
yeah i don't know if that's bad is it
yeah no because i mean i'm drinking the
faucet one right right right i used to
drink out of hoses as a kid right right
spike it we'd find a spicket on the side
of a building turn it on and drink out
of that why don't we have to get racist
but
what sorry i was a racist child yeah no
yeah you know it's true i mean but the
thing is too it's good
cause i'm just saying like you know as
we as generations are moving on you know
i know people say we're getting softer
and that's a generalization overall
though it seems like we are because you
know like it was very very like my like
you know your i don't know if was your
mother a smoker or no yeah your mother
at one point may have smoked cigarettes
when she was pregnant with you not
because she was trying to do any male
intent and my mother i'm intense
we're in the court of law okay
yeah um
not with any because it's just at that
time like in the 60s 70s 80s there was
no research that smoking harmed the baby
so like now it's like if you even
breathe in second-hand smoke like women
back no no if i smoke one cigarette like
my kid's going to be deformed when i was
like from
millennia yeah we're just breathing [ __ ]
in and everybody was fine yeah so i
remember when i was really like when i
was a kid my mom if she had to smoke she
wouldn't smoke in the house but she
would go into the bathroom and smoke
and and then she'd come out and out of
the bathroom right like she'd have a
quick cigarette in the bathroom she
wasn't smoking in the house right so i
guess she kind of knew
i don't know i should ask her if she
smoked with me when she was prank
[ __ ] marry kill mom down grandma all
right well obviously i'd [ __ ] my dad
imagine
i did want to bring up sal told us the
first thing he does when he enters a
hotel room
what is that what is the first thing he
does i mean i dropped my bag and before
i do a single thing i pick up the phone
i order four pillows
i order four more pillows usually
there's at least four sometimes they'll
try to pull a fast one on you and
there's like three
but sometimes you come in and there's
like a pillow that is
as good as a a a a pillow case with
nothing in it you ever seen those
they're like flapjacks flapjacks they
they they are this thin you could stack
three in a row it's not the same as a
regular sized pillow shout out the
ramada in bloomington minnesota i stayed
there when i was doing the house of
comedy in the mall of american
bloomington minnesota the pillows were
like concrete that i remember each night
i was there for four nights because i
was doing a wednesday to sunday
i slept on my book bag i filled my book
bag up with my dirty laundry and used
that as a pillow that's right i could
have at any point just did what you
didn't call and ask for extra pillows
but at that point in my travel
experience i didn't know you could do
that yeah you can't even do that
you said there's a pillow menu yes
that's crazy no but you you i mean and i
i like a little bit like nicer or hotels
are trying to go the extra mile like
i've even had a pillow menu at like a an
airport westin
yeah really are they from hamlocker and
schmeller
hammacker
hammacher schlemmer the best gift i've
ever received from anybody including
like the gift of life my mother gave me
even better than that is sal's gave me a
pillow from hemlock on schlimmer one
year for christmas and it was the best
thing i've ever gotten i still to this
day have that pillow if literally
literally if you threw me out of my
house and burnt everything if you burnt
my clothes on fire and said get out as
long as i had that pillow i'd be fine i
could recover you you still have that so
i still have mine i used them it was
cooling gel too there was like these
little yeah like these little like
little like uh lines in it that have
cool engines can't get hot you know cool
is the other side of the pillow you're
always on the other side of the shout
out stuart smith stuart scott r.i.p rp
students
um
but mine have have gone the way of the
dodo bird now mine are no good mine are
getting shoddy they don't stay cold
anymore they're
i mean i've used them for four years you
know what i got to be honest with you
and listen they haven't been they're not
a sponsor now i doubt they'll be a
sponsor but i got to be honest with you
and this may be painful yeah
tommy john does not last i have got
holes
in holes
in my tommy john underwear like i'm
talking about full holes where i sit
down my nuts
hit the back of my pants i'm telling you
this this is what i think i think you're
using fabric softener
because i've had i have like 30 pairs
and i
i have finally got my first hole in one
of them finally but why but sal how can
i how can i have a pair of underwear
that can't survive fabric softener it's
got to survive
chili farts
i think it's the type of fabric it is
you have the second skin
yes yeah i think that it's something
something reacts with the second skin
fabric i'd love to watch chris do his
laundry what is your laundry my laundry
first of all i do it you you drop it off
no i do my i do my laundry full-on do my
lunch i do my kids laundry i do laundry
the only thing i do because i just think
it's a myth i don't separate whites and
and colors i just throw them all in and
i've never had a problem i've never had
a problem with any item of clothing
that's gotten ruined you're very
progressive granted exactly i'm not i
ain't about that segregation
shout out sean king you've taught me i i
but the only thing i will say is i don't
have a lot of white clothing yeah so
maybe that so so pretty much when i'm
you know anything that i have that's not
black or dark
is underwear and i don't nobody cares
about those nobody's separating their
undies right but that's but that's what
so you do your own laundry so do you use
fabric softener i use um i use okay so i
have these um i don't know what they're
called but it's a cap you put a cap full
of of it in first they're like little
pebbles that are supposed to be like get
you know what i'm talking about
what is it called that softener but
they're supposed to like get out the
athletic if they're for like athlete
athleisure stuff where it's like if you
got like that stinky like when your
clothes smell like a wet mop after
exercise it's supposed to get that smell
out and then i put a cup full of tide
either directly onto the clothes or i
pull out the little thing on my um in my
washing machine yeah but i don't know if
i'm supposed to pour them directly onto
the clothes but i don't think you are i
think it's a support in the water
why if you pour it onto the direct
clothes what does that do it ruins the
clothes i think it's not going to be um
just my guess it's not going to be
distributed properly how many dryer
sheets do you use on on a on a on a
moderate load how many dryer sheets will
you put in
how many dryer sheets do you put on a
dryer load of laundry
two to three two three see that that's
the only issue that i have and i've been
spoken to about that by jasmine i put
upwards of ten dryer sheets in the dryer
you wanna know why you're tommy john's
getting holes blown in them too much i
for me it can't be dry enough you listen
pick yourself up pick yourself up some
dryer balls
wait hold on hold on wait a second you
have to drive do you have a tie pod
shadow tag pot challenge yeah but dryer
dryer balls yeah dryer balls pick
yourself up some so you just don't use
these balls that you throw into the
dryer i've seen them as like um almost
like cloth type balls and i've also seen
them as like hard rubber with like
almost like um little uh little uh like
spikes on them like like they look like
the coronavirus virus and you throw like
three or four in there and they just
they just bounce around they do their
thing and they i guess what the theory
is that they kind of keep the clothes
flipping and flopping and they hit they
like they hit into them and they keep
moving them with the weight of the balls
and then like hitting them and i think
that it helps uh it helps coax them to
dry faster and more evenly am i right
about that
well well why wasn't that 100 right
she's saying they're wool
they massage the fabric so it's and it
softens it naturally
did right now it's 20 20 well when this
episode will come out in 2021 we're on
the verge on the precipice of 2022. you
know what he gets a cuban link bracelet
and he's dropping words like valentine's
precipice i'm a different person i'm a
different person i swear to god i i we
have done 60 episodes those are the two
biggest words you've ever used
back-to-back
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
unbelievable
um
to this day my aunt janet shout out my
aunt janet to this day i mean fully
gorgeous fully renovated house on i mean
you know
you know very um you know like new
school like us you know knows you know
like probably knows like all adele's new
songs and drake's new songs you know
very modern woman
she has an air fryer
she has an air fryer like she's she's on
the net you know what i mean she's got
yeah she's with it she knows she knows
what's going on yeah
she to this day has our washing machine
in her kitchen washes her clothes has
ample space for a dryer but instead puts
her clothes out on a clothesline
old school with a crank that she has
puts him on and then has to
run feverishly watches the news
watches the news like she's in an air
traffic control tower to make sure that
it's not going to rain and then gets the
clothes back in if there's even the
slightest chance of rain to this day she
air dries her clothes
why does she prefer does she tell you
she's she said she said it's the way
i've always done it it's what i'm
comfortable with she's like you know
whatever i'm 55 years old i'm not going
to change it now
she's 55 years old and she knows all of
drake's new hits all drake's new hits
shout out my channel every time drake
drops something yeah
she knows it she has she's my
grandparents used to have we had no
dryer when i live with my grandparents
growing up we had no dryer actually the
house couldn't handle it the electricity
in the house couldn't handle it was an
older house
and we uh line hung all everything to
dry
right and my we had a big big my
grandfather the length of the house we
had an attic a full
height addict the length of the house
then they they hung the rope from one
end of the house to the other in the
attic so they would go up to the attic
to hang clothes that must be fun though
hey what's wrong we go up there with the
dogs the dogs be running back and forth
hey listen babel
i've been learning a new language i
literally
been learning i've learned 14 languages
which one have you learned i've learned
spanish french and russian that's
unbelievable fully fluent b-a-b-b-e-l
it's a language learning app it's our
favorite they have 15-minute bite-sized
lessons they make it fun
and every other learning language app
uses artificial intelligence ai not them
no they use actual language experts
linguistics came together they came from
all different races religions cultures
and creed they came together i wanted to
make babble this is it you want to
connect with your grandparents you want
to travel you want to impress a gal
whatever you want to do or a guy you
want to just you want to be able to
watch salamundo whatever you whatever it
is
yes babel will help you get there and
it's a fun way to learn it's a fun way
to learn and you're going to get a sick
discount the discount on babel is
unbelievable if you go to babel.com
right now and use the promo code hey
babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com promo code hey babe you
get three months free on a six-month
subscription right so if you purchase
three months right as you purchase a
three-month subscription you get an
additional three for a six-month
subscription for the price of a
three-month subscription all you gotta
do is go to babel.com promo code hey
babe tell us that you did it in the
language that you learned that's b a b b
e l dot com
slash hey babe that's what it is babble
language for life this podcast is
sponsored by better health boom boom we
love better help i use it sally babes
uses it homeless pimp uses it we love we
love better help they've helped us
they've been with us for forever from
dave literally i don't think i could
have gone through this podcast for a
year without the help of that coming up
we just passed our anniversary we're at
the last episode the last episode of the
year better help us we've been with us
through a lot of it and you can start
communicating with uh with a health
healthcare mental health professional in
under 48 hours there's a broad range of
expertise available um services
available for clients worldwide better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist it's really good it's all done
securely online online you don't have to
worry about covet health message your
counselor whenever you want whatever you
want they pull counselors from
everywhere so you'd have uh more options
than if you were searching locally yes
okay yes
but you know that's why we're on there
we're learning we're learning and if you
go to betterhelp.com
hey babe that's better h-e-l-p dot com
slash hey babe you're gonna get ten
percent off your first month okay and
that's huge everybody's got mental
health issues right now betterhelp.com
hey babe 10 first month that's a nice
savings i have a house or when you were
a little kid or be in a house that had a
laundry chute
no like a laundry chute that's so that
feels like something from webster yeah
no one i had a friend no webster
you know what you talking about with us
lewis well that's arnold jackson who
played by uh
gary coleman
but is that believe it or not in the 80s
in the late 80s and 80s late 80s there
were two
small
i guess they weren't little p were they
little people
yeah they were no they weren't little
people though
gary coleman and emmanuel lewis were two
young black boys that were older than
they appeared
that that that um that were television
sitcoms stars in different sitcoms yeah
so what you talking about willis is
different strokes okay and webster
was the titular
titular yeah
character titular you're using cuban
link words right now emmanuel lewis
yeah and then so he's his little little
small fry see by the way papadopoulos
was his father on the show
uh he's a guy from he's a football
player
that guy he's a football player by the
way is there anyone pimp that you've
ever met in your life
who's a white man in his 40s that's
watched more black sitcoms than sal
volcano no black sitcoms on my jam
that's you everything there's not a
black sitcom that sal hasn't seen fully
every episode end-to-end they're the
best sitcoms they actually are yeah i
mean
fresh prince of bel-air in my opinion is
one of the best sitcoms of all time
family matters one of the best of all
time love it you heard they're gonna
bring back fresh prince as a serious
drama
that i don't want them to do i heard the
cast no no no with a young cast oh f
that i don't want to who's got time for
that ain't nobody got time to be honest
with you because even the i like because
even like um uh full house when they
brought it back on netflix i just didn't
love it it just yeah there was some you
know stephanie was on crack like i
didn't like you guys like sequels
no
okay
if it's done right the only sequel
the sequel that i'll say that i would
pro i prefer of the original and i know
people may go into uproar right now and
go crazy but i'm gonna tell you it and
it's a tie i'll give you two i'll give
you two sequels that i think are in my
opinion light years better than the
first one
okay movie the show movie okay
two
wayne's world two okay
back to the future too
oh i don't think back to the future two
is light years ahead of one see i like
twos i thought i knew where you were
going with this i thought you were going
to say two can i tell you something even
crazy that you may that like listen if i
get punched in the face this i can punch
in the face for this back to the future
three is better than the first two
that's what q thinks and it's my least
favorite one
did he just say that on taste buds are
we on taste buds
he he contends that that's his favorite
one and i'm like it's my least favorite
one back to the future three in my
opinion is better than one and two
combined
oh that's junior punch in the face on
the streets now listen to me don't hit
him too hard when you see him no i mean
good times
uh the jeffersons sanford and son uh
even martin's so funny too martin's
classic yeah
i will tell you something i don't think
we've mentioned this on hay babe yet
have i talked about yellowstone did i
talk about it on last hey babe
i watched the first episode i'm sure and
you didn't like the first episode i did
but you fell asleep no
she fell asleep
okay i watched the first step and i and
i saw all the happenings at the end if
you recall yes s goes down yep and then
i'm ready to watch part two let me tell
you something right now the opening
episode of season four of yellowstone
is is
it is the best
episode i've ever seen of a television
show period end of sentence
from the from the action to the drama to
the soundtrack got it all it's got it
all and now here's the thing about
what's happening now now
if you watch yellowstone
in the middle of yellowstone yeah like
season three they decide to get another
storyline going about
the
about what the kevin costner's his name
is john dutton in the show and he and
he's on the du and ranch yeah so they
decide uh randomly in season three one
of the episodes just opens up like
episode six or something like that just
opens up of what the ranch looked like
in 1883 like the beginning of the dutton
ranch and tim mcgraw is playing kevin
country music's
star tim mcgraw and faith hill are the
lead characters country music's faith
hill country are they married
cmt superstar i think they are isn't
vader hill and zimmer girl i think they
are aren't they married no they are
cmt superstars
tim mcgraw and faith hill does retail
saying man i feel like a woman
and by the way that song i mean that
will open up next episode with that man
i feel like hey babe
[Laughter]
let's go girls
so with emmanuel lewis on a sitcom there
was you know what a dumb waiter is a
dumb waiter yeah yeah the guy we had
last night
no i'm kidding yeah it's a pulley system
it's a little door in a house and it
with a platter on it and it's like a
pulley
i guess maybe there's electric ones i
don't know but old school and it would
be on old like mansions and or old big
home victorian homes or what have you so
they could transport food and things
down to another
so in webster there was a dumb waiter in
the house and they used to put the kid
in there he was a little the little kid
and they used to br he they used to put
him downstairs how many kids got killed
in a dumb waiter over the years so i
have to be i have to be a lot yeah
that's why they stopped making them so
let me tell you something real quick
about 1883. so so 1883 is i've never
seen a television show do this
yellowstone is happening yeah all of a
sudden the middle of season three they
unreal unveil that you think it's just
doing flashbacks like oh tim mcgraw is
in this show that's interesting he
[ __ ] did a little bit part in the
show
all of a sudden paramount plus comes out
and says we're making an entire show
called 1883 and we're airing the first
episodes and second episodes of 1883
while season four of yellowstone is
happening simultaneously so characters
of two television shows
and then you're ready for this you ready
for this i'm no i don't know if i am
there's a scene
hold on
what i'm about to tell you make sure
your balls are secure all right there's
a scene
in 1883 where tim mcgraw wakes up on the
battlefield of antietam battle which is
a real battle happening in in the civil
war he wakes up on the battlefield
and love is
as a confederate soldier because he's
from texas you know you'll get the story
of they migrate from texas to montana
with the dutton ranches
um uh he wakes up on the battlefield as
a confederate soldier and everyone in
his platoon or whatever is dead because
he's a general and then he sits down and
the union army which is still there
because they just won the battle
you know sees him get up and instead of
killing him the leader of the union army
of that battle walks over and you could
just see the union army union army
soldiers shoes and pants he sits down
tim mcgraw starts crying they're sitting
on a bench together in the middle of the
battlefield timmy girl starts crying
and the union soldier is just rubbing
his back spoiler alert no no he's just
rubbing his back saying i know buddy i
know meaning like he understands what
the war is and how okay what he's
dealing with and you're like oh wow
that's cool that's a nice scene then the
camera pans up you know who the union
soldier is
tom hanks
television and movies tom hanks
philadelphia's own thomas no way he's in
him he's in a tv show now he survived
aids and made it all the way to 1883. he
went back in time to 1883. tom hanks oh
if they're pulling tom hanks this thing
has to be huge
and then and see so you so you're like i
can't believe they got tom hanks that
must they must have blown their budget
episode two the sheriff of one of the
towns that they just migrate into mick
jagger
billy bob thornton
well i would have done billy bob's one
first
then mick jack no then then tom hanks
it's hard to follow tonight because you
like you because you think they blew
that bunch up you know where's billy bob
thornton been he's never seen him since
bed said he's stuck in 1883
which show do you like better
you want to you want to know you want to
know the truth
i i told you
two weeks ago privately yeah but i'll
share on the podcast that yellowstone
was the best show i've ever seen i told
you that it was the sopranos if it took
place in montana and i meant that okay
after seeing two full episodes of 1883
i'm ready to tell you that 1883 is the
best show i've ever seen in my life
you're telling me that a period piece
yes a period drama even yes from the
1800s two episodes you've seen
1883 it's like if the sopranos took
place in the wild wild west in 1883 wow
[Laughter]
you know the show webster is as if the
sopranos lived uh with a football player
george papadopoulos and they put all the
sopranos in the dumb waiter and put them
up and down that's like webster imagine
james gayle doffini has a little black
boy yeah that's right
again no uh okay you ready for this yes
i got another idea for a guest for hay
babe okay okay there's a man and he's
all over the five characters from the
sopranos
go
james gameloffini christopher
[ __ ] aj yeah edie falco
i'm out i'm out you're all over the
charts i'm out i'm out okay so is my
heart rate um
there's a man who faked being who faked
being disabled to get his diaper changed
has been arrested again so there was a
man walking around making believe he was
disabled just because he had a fetish
that he liked wearing a diaper that guy
right there and then would get his
diaper changed would get his diaper
changed he's been arrested now for about
the fifth time what photo is that of him
he looks like a deranged lunatic well we
were wondering if we could get him if if
if he's vaccinated will wear a mask if
he'd come on hey
how could he get be arrested like after
the third time
he's like oh he did it again there's a
lot how is he still able to do it
there's a lot of people that fake
disabilities that's a very very very
common thing to fake because you get so
much service and assistance you ever see
speaking of doing those investigative
reports at the hotels you ever see the
one where they sometimes they'll follow
people that are on a corner with a sign
asking for money saying they're disabled
and uh they they did a whole report and
there was like a guy with crutches with
like asking for money all day and they
followed him and he'd like go on the
card and then once he got around the
corner he'd just take his crutches throw
in his car and just drive away he fell
into his house he was a regular guy with
a regular job another they found they
found a woman doing it well well i'm
going to call it have you ever been
conned no i i haven't been well uh all
year long yes all your life yeah
actually yes i've been taught okay i've
been con i'm just naive about it i've
been [ __ ] um
you're about to say something we'll come
back to the con nope speaking of a khan
i want and i want to i want to name
names right now his name is charlie
kipovic kipidovic if you get an email
from him as a comedian do not give him
anything he makes believe that he has
cancer and all these other things to get
free uh autographed signings merchandise
tickets it's all a lie it's all a lie so
if you get that he uses his real name or
or that you know he's assuming it
changes his name but it's it's a lie he
doesn't have any of this stuff also we
have some bad news about an nfl legend
john madden just died john madden oh i
have to be honest with you and this is
no respect i thought john madden died in
2018.
i i granted i haven't heard much from
madden in a while outside of the game no
but i love john madden but he just died
meaning like while we were he died today
yeah oh wow
that sucks
just another legend yeah that's that's
sad
hope he's john madden i got an end zone
in the sky i've never i've never um i've
never i mean that heartfelt
john
i loved him in little giants he was he
little giants yeah he was in a play
he was in uh one part of little giants
when the the football players um
show up to the little giants camp
because their their tour bus made a
wrong turn remember and they like tell
them you you know you know the scene of
little giants do you know little giants
yeah i do i i you people take these for
uh indigestion what do you take them for
intimidation
yeah then the freezer the fruit the
freezer yeah becky o'donnell uh uh the
free uh no what was it the icebox the
icebox yeah and then these are their
famous players called the annexation of
puerto rico yeah
yeah i don't remember maddening it
though matt yeah
how old was he pimp
uh 85. that's a nice life you make it to
the cause you know here's the truth to
the situation you don't really want to
get into the 90s and hundreds because
you're most likely going to live a very
painful life you're not controlling your
balance i feel like 85 is nuts yeah
unless you're a together 100 year old
like casey jose and nick collin their
grandmother i think is like 103 lives on
her own lives on her own yeah i think
she she's a writer for snl
isn't that amazing like when i was
little in my head for some reason i was
like 100 is what you live too right i
always just thought oh 100 because my
great-grandma lived to 99. oh my god wow
and then you know and then so on and so
forth i had older people in the family
and i just always saw like
some for some reason a hundred stood out
to me as a round number
and it was just like a hundred it's a
hundred cents and a dollar a hundred i
just a hundred
when i say hello fresh what do you say
america's number one meal kit i'm
telling you sam what am i [ __ ] no
you're not because you're using hello
fresh now you've i've been cooking i've
been learning how to cook and now i
would say no i was learning how to cook
with hello fresh now i'd say because of
the amount of time i've been with them i
know how to cook you leveled up now
whatever you want whatever you want
you're now a cook we're gonna become a
better cook you can get gordon ramsay in
here i'll punch him in the face with a
fistful of paparazzi that i made from
hellofresh that's what it is that's what
it is new year's is a great time to
focus on what's most important to you
whether it's saving money or ordering
less takeout learning to cook
prioritizing your wellness all that
jibber jabber hello fresh she's here to
help with endless options to make
cooking at home simple and enjoyable how
about this and they got the quick and
easy meals they take 20 minutes to make
clean up they have 30 minute versions 20
minute versions and the food is
fantastic and you ready for this you
want to know what i'm about tell you
right now they got desserts now you want
to know what the desserts is please hold
your balls
dunkaroose dunkaroo's cookie dough
dunkaroos cookie dough
they're unbelievable and they're 72
cheaper than a restaurant meal of the
same quality that's over 65 per month
you save and right now and here's what i
want to tell you listen to me right now
put down stop what you're doing because
the promo code i'm about to tell you is
real we have to fact check this with
haven't been saying are you sure you're
running a business this way because it's
like it feels like you're not making any
money to do this ready for this if you
go to
hellofresh.com slash hey babe16 and use
the code heybabe16 you're going to get
16 free meals plus 3 free gifts 16 free
meals 3 free gifts if you go to hey babe
if you go to hellofresh.com hey babe 16.
i mean there's no better deal than that
it sells itself hellofresh america's
number one meal kit all right babe
there's this app
called true bill i know true bills baby
i love you i put true bill in the words
true blue bar madonna and it was a fun
little thing i did true bill yeah what
it does is
you know like when you when you
subscribe to something you forget about
it yeah this this auto subscription [ __ ]
yes true bills that's how they get you
that's how they get you true bill goes
do the computer and unsubscribes you to
everything you're not using it is the
greatest invention yeah i have ever used
i literally i'm i don't know oh so they
say on average it saves up to 720 zero
true bill i got to be honest with you in
one month i've used it i saved six
hundred dollars there was six hundred
dollars of bills that i was paying gym
fees uh phone things you know this that
all these apps i was paying for gone
yeah it's like a true build it's like
you have someone looking over you that
goes to all the companies and goes oh no
no no no no no no you're not going to do
that to him
yes yeah or they and it's like or they
and it's electronic i love true bill
they save me so much money all you got
to do is link your accounts and true
bill will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions in just one tap tap tap
tap tap tab tab two million users
they're up to right now it's crazy dude
and i'm seeing now i'm starting to see
the kid who he's like a 27 20 year old
kid who made true build starting to see
commercials for him all over tv because
his app is exploring this kid must be
worth 100 mil yeah the kid found a hole
and he filled it
fill in the holes so don't scroll a
little bit so start so start cancelling
your subscriptions right now don't
follow your subscription scams at all
the only subscription you need is the
screwball
don't fail for subscription scams start
canceling today at truebill.com slash
hey babe
that's all you got to do is go right
hey
now
it could save you thousands a year
truebuild.com hey babe
well you always hear them do on the news
like that they do the birthdays yeah
like in the on the news and they would
be like happy birthday and always be
like people in their late 90s yeah and
so for me when people start dropping
like flies in the 70s and 80s i'm like
oh my god that's why i know who's going
to probably play football to their 100
tom brady yeah shout out tom brady
he's a champ he's a super bowl champion
won the super bowl buccaneers in their
home stadium nonetheless yeah and
speaking he's not far from 100 because
he's already the oldest guy in the nfl
by far
but one of the youngest guys in the nfl
be remiss we'd be remiss if we didn't
mention him kansas city chiefs what a
stellar style performance he's from
right here he's from maddie mae holmes
he's from texas patrick holmes his
brother's an [ __ ] jackson my humps um
personal experience no no he's it's all
over like uh you know his brother
jackson mahomes his brother's like keeps
getting in trouble i actually don't know
what he's like my brother you know my
brother his brothers acts like a like a
like a pompous jerk-off like people
don't like him yeah like he does sounds
like a fake name just throws them out a
little bit yeah nfl reporter takes
savage shot at brittany matthew yeah
downtown uh calls out jack oh yeah
jackson hall he wrote he did something
where like he went online and like
really [ __ ] on like a a bar restaurant
and the waiter waitresses performance
there and then they wrote something a
back yeah let's go into this jackson
mahomes i can't see today so yeah go
down go down a little bit uh pimpy the
the or uh the
i don't know what this is is that i know
patrick looks visibly angry at his
brother um
is he a young kid yeah has that ever
happened to you guys like somebody used
your name and embarrassed you at a place
you weren't at
somebody i i tell a joke about change
but it is true somebody made a fully
fake grinder account with all of my
pictures and information and there has
been multiple people that have dm'd me
gay men of dm me be like hey i match
with you on grindr like
let's hang out i'm wherever and i'm like
that's not me that's not you that's not
me if you want to know where i am i
meant this hotel this room
i have some facts about pillows oh here
we go when do you think if you had to
guess the oldest known pillow
i got a feeling what do you really think
yeah okay so we go back to like
aboriginal times yeah okay like caveman
times yes they didn't have pillows but i
think someone somewhere along the early
years had to fashion
a sack
or a satchel of leaves
right they had to put two and two
together i mean if they're inventing the
wheel on fire a pillow can't be far
behind you ready for this yeah pillows
date back to mesopotamia shout out over
9 000 years ago the ancient egyptians
used pillows but they were more
interested in protecting the head
because it was seen as the spiritual
center of their bodies comfort was
strictly optional the chinese were also
fans of the hard pillow ah they'd
probably run that place at the hotel you
were at yes the hard pillow oh yeah
your pillows are made of stone six
pillows i sleep with
six could you sleep on a stone pillow
no no no no what's a stone pillow what
is it even they said pillows pillows
were used to be made of stone and
understandably less comfortable very
unlike what we think as of pillows today
in fact it said that these stone pillows
were made to help keep bugs from calling
into the ears of wealthier citizens oh
speaking of bugs the story that he told
today at breakfast you have to tell them
when you went to australia
oh [ __ ]
it was a little thing where i was like
what i i couldn't believe being in this
situation bro tell them i was in the
desert in australia i like you too
and uh i was staying in like a little
like a little uh well don't get me wrong
it was a nice room but it was like it
was like this you see kangaroo
you know i didn't i didn't see kangaroos
koalas you had to go to like a sanctuary
for that i didn't see him roman so
there's not like a sign like you know
like when we're driving like you know
wherever in upstate new york wherever it
says sign for deer there's no sign for
kangaroo i didn't see that i thought
kangaroos were like the deers of i
thought they were like deer we wanted to
see them and they were like oh you have
to go to like the preserve or whatever i
don't know what would you rather do real
quick fight jake paul or kangaroo i'd
rather fight oh uh
i think a kangaroo would be much more
interesting right you know if you're
gonna get knocked out you're gonna get
knocked up by kangaroo yeah did you ever
see that video of that guy the
kangaroo's [ __ ] with his dog and he
runs out squares up with the kangaroo
and literally punches the kangaroo in
the face and the kangaroo is like
stunned and he just walks away no
squares up you go
you got to put this in it's the funniest
thing you'll ever see
look at this
i mean you started from the beginning
though you have to be drunk to square up
with this freaking thing look it's like
the kangaroo is like like he gets into
it they square up on each other it's
amazing
look he runs off because he sees the
kangaroo messing with his dog look this
guy lives on a big field this guy is
just this is like look the kangaroo has
his dog around the neck in a headlock
what does he want to do to the dog
what does he want to swatch
then the kangaroo is just stunned
[Laughter]
he just leaves he just is like see ya
dude wow how funny is that they're the
scariest animal i think that is
[Laughter]
i want to say kangaroos are scary but
also for me like i personally think the
scariest thing is an alligator that's
scarier to me than even a shark because
an alligator like they they want to eat
you like alive they like drown you first
they like roll you around i don't wanna
i don't wanna get eaten alive by a sea
creature if i was gonna eat alive i'd
prefer to be eaten alive by a land
animal let me ask you a question if an
alligator was on land what's their top
speed can you out run an alligator on
land well i think i have very short
limbs so i want to say no i would say
that especially with the work i'm doing
on my flexibility in hamstrings yeah i
think that i'd be able to outrun an
alligator since i started doing yoga
with your lady you had on her yeah shout
out to her shout out shivasi now you're
not going anywhere they run 20 miles an
hour yeah i probably can't beat that's a
short still short little legs they get
up to 20 miles an hour see i always do
can you see a video can you google pimp
uh video uh alligator running or
something like that i always thought
here we go if you weren't in the in the
swamp and you got out to the land
because they always just go so slow i
always just thought oh they're not going
to chase you i heard you have to run in
a zigzag to get away because they know
that they can't change direction you're
right you're right pimp they can't
change the direction like at the end
yeah look wow this is the end of an
episode of benny hill
you know what's crazy is i'm reading uh
a book um called uh can't hurt me
i thought you were gonna end the answer
the first sentence with david you know
it's crazy i'm reading a book period and
then pimp zooms into my face
so david goggins book can't hurt me and
i'm pretty sure they said to
and i could be wrong i know if people
might have went through this i'm sorry
if i was reading it on the on the on the
van today but
to start to get through i think it's
green ranger school to become like a
green ranger like the leader of the
elite power and drop you yet become
power tommy the white ranger yeah they
drop you off in a helicopter like the
military drops you off and i think the
everglades are a swamp and you have to
wade through waters you have your weapon
all that and basically get through
you know survive to get the job you have
to survive it like and not get in by an
alligator or not get you know killed
somehow they give you no food like you
have to pass these elite elite tests
every single year like there's not been
a year that's went by where somebody in
one of these specialized school training
navy seals green range whatever they die
in training every year somebody dies wow
constantly in navy seal school they
they are actively trying to drown you
you were they don't care if you die like
you have to sign waivers and they tell
your family like if if they're gonna
pass this they have to go through like
they have to see the light
they have to oh my god
that's all it's about that's why they
say like if you're like a navy seal or a
green ranger like your skill set is
basically you're like the strength of
like six soldiers so what they'll say
once you're that far into being a
killing machine can you just enjoy small
things i don't think you can do it yeah
i mean are you really like when you when
you leave the navy seals are you really
going to work out like staples no their
brains are permanent what does the navy
seal get what's the salary of a navy
seal i want to say okay can they delete
their elite right they have to be deaf
i'm going to say they don't make any
more than 80k
i think why would you do it
honor salary as how much do navy seals
and special ops make 76k oh my god
how are you that close i've been i've
been researching
are you kidding me okay but the the
range is from 59 to 424 so if you're
making 420 average salary
but but 80k is what you make yeah but
you imagine okay ready me and you get a
me and you are navy seals we get a
mission we get a mission together we're
out in the [ __ ] tundra right right
we're we're sleeping inside the carcass
of a hippo in a tundra right i don't
even know if it goes together and we
start to [ __ ] and you drop on me
that you make 424 thousand dollars and
you're like what are you making i'm like
15 nine
i would kill you right now right there i
would kill your death yeah wow well
something what do you got to do to be a
navy seal that makes a half
that makes that makes a half
do you know what they have did it say
four how much 400 000 something but that
must be like an officer
that must be the top navy seal that must
be like that that's like like like
rambo ramp isn't the real money like
getting through being a navy seal and
then going private so that's where all
the money is when you become a mercenary
mercenary yeah so but but you know to
survive navy seal there's this thing
called hell week where they keep you
awake like you're fully awake doing
they're running 20 miles a day
exercising all day doing all these
things they keep you awake for like 15
days
fully awake i think that you could do
permanent damage they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] google navy seal
hell week it's the crate when i was
reading it i was like and i can't get on
the elliptical for 25 minutes
i know and i like that this guy's like
i'm up for day 14. it's i gotta stay
awake for every every thousand dollars
of my starting salary yeah yeah the
fourth week of basic conditioning is
known as hell week this one students
train for five and a half days sorry
five and a half days with a maximum
total of four hours of sleep oh my in
the
five and a half days begins midnight
sunday and ends friday afternoon during
this time trainees face and they put
it's in san diego and they have them go
in the freezing cold water who wants to
do this you gotta that's what you have
to do if you want to become a navy seal
i'm in the desert
i go back to my room there's little like
huts in the desert australia we're back
to australia yeah i'm in australia i go
back to my room i had to eat like some
dinner somewhere and i go to walk up to
my door and there is
yeah and there's a tarantula on the
doorknob to my tarantula is the thing
i've legitimately only seen in movies
yeah like the only time i've seen it
ranch's home alone you saw this is on
your door it was on the doorknob like
like it's like comically on the doorknob
like the only place i have anything as
big as a doorknob like could you in
other words maneuver your hand around
absolutely not there was no getting i i
was like do i wait will he walk away
well let's just say worst case scenario
you want to open the doors you really
answer [ __ ] would you
would you if a tarantula stung you is
that poison
some i think and some not i don't give a
flying [ __ ] either way did the most
disgusting australia probably poison
everything bugs i don't care about bugs
i could live amongst roaches and
tarantulas mice and rats i can't uh
on the san antonio river walk last night
we were drinking 40s out of straws me
and pimp like real pieces of [ __ ] i
thought it possibly were possible that
riverwalk is shady [ __ ] man the last
time i stayed at the omni on the river
walk in san antonio i dreamt i was so
scared because it was very musty i said
there's got to be water bugs in here i
went to sleep i grabbed myself like a
burrito so i wouldn't get attacked i
dreamt that a billion roaches came from
the ceilings and combined and made a
super roach i had a nightmare i woke up
in a cold sweat it was the morning i got
up i wanted to get out of there i went
to the bathroom to wash up i moved my
toiletry bag and there was a a it was a
water bug that big i dreamt it into
fruition you manifested and that was
right by what you saw the possum so
there's shady stuff going on down there
and also before we go because we're at
the end of the episode it's the new
year's eve episode
you know wow it is new year's eve
in cincinnati
oh yeah in cincinnati tomorrow we're in
cincinnati tomorrow that's right and
tonight we're in columbus ohio right now
we're in columbus ohio tonight
cincinnati tomorrow yeah so if you're in
that area come hang out new year's eve
with us yeah we're gonna have to have
palace theater tonight right
tonight taft dinner tomorrow if we sell
out tomorrow we are going inviting the
entire crowd to where we are going to
hang out we might invite them back to
our ho
wait wait we actually extended that to
columbus and cincinnati we did so it's
up to you if you want to hang out it's
up to you we want to do that for you
come to the shows i'm telling you the
shows that we've been doing
i go out and do half an hour of stand up
sal goes on does half an hour stand up
then we both come back out together and
do like a mini hey babe where we ask the
audience questions so if you're on the
fence and you want to be a part of the
show or love this show come see it and
there's surprises we got open acts
sometimes friends drop in like today tim
dillon is going to be on the show
tonight just pulled up in ohio because
hometown guy we got lebron james that's
coming he's coming ohio yeah who else is
from ohio who else from ohio i mean
lebron is all you need really the bronze
from do a tight five yes come to my
hotel we'll party after if it sells out
i check in under the name glaca dean
capisce blackadine kabish
so baby it's been great we hope you guys
are having fun yeah right now right now
it's
it's seven minutes till showtime
literally though i just want to say this
2021 at least for me has been the best
year of my career
um
because of the fans and and how it
everything has changed i just want to
say uh ernest heartfelt thank you very
much to all the fans that have uh
subscribed to the heybay podcast and the
chrissy chaos podcast but we're on hey
babe so i really do genuinely mean that
cause sal and i weren't sure if we were
gonna start the show took a while to
start but i'm just i'm happy we started
and we did it baby 100 man yeah we were
talking about that for a while
and uh
yeah we did it and and it flew by the
year like that we've got a couple
hundred thousand subscribers we're doing
live shows together yeah and uh the
patreon's coming out too hey trans
facebook you know what is really coming
out to god two weeks merch mercury weeks
and if you've come to the shows we've
been we've sold out of the merch like
that double wear shirt so merch is gone
already gone uh there'll be more merch
in st louis and more merchant ohio texas
merch is gone we're gonna have three
t-shirts a hoodie socks stickers
shoelaces we might be dropping a denim
jacket uh it's all in being printed
right now though the hard work is done
the online store will be up in a couple
of weeks same thing for taste taste buds
too all right baby yeah well it's been
good enjoy your new year stay safe out
there for the last time in 2021 this has
been
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey